well hi sophia it's so good to see you
over here
but still good i feel like if we do this
we're almost hugging
yeah just like hey
how was the the pandemic quarantine like
how was the past year and a half been on
you
i mean i think it's been i think it's
been so many things
i i had to figure out what my own silver
linings
of this year could be you know otherwise
i don't think it would have been
survivable and there are things that i
feel so
lucky to have had some of the time and
space to do
it's been a rollercoaster ride but i
know that that's the thing
even though the the individual
experiences are unique to us
i know that's the thing we're really all
in together
as more and more people get vaccinated
and do so
as an act of love not only for
themselves but their communities
i i hope that we'll be more and more
back to normal more quickly
yeah me too light at the end of the
tunnel oh
dark it's been a dark year and a half or
so so it does feel like there's
light at least um
some good news you bethany
and hillary speaking up for a new
podcast called
drama queens why would now the time to
sort of reunite
on a project and really dive into the
the stories that you guys have from your
time
on one tree hill i mean we've been
talking about it forever and the fans
really are just so incredible and they
keep the love for the show like
pumping at you full speed and
we have been approached about reboots
and things and
it's always so hectic to try to figure i
mean there were like a million of us on
our show
it's complicated um but but
one of the sort of by-products of the
initial
lockdown i was doing my podcast i was
doing work in progress
uh you know the thing i was able to do
every day was record at home and
interviewing
so many incredible people and thought
leaders and activists and
you know everyone from jameel smith to
hillary clinton and having these
phenomenal conversations
that were really inspiring to me and i
found myself being so
fulfilled by that and at night wanting
to watch
old shows that i loved like watch sex in
the city for the fifth time
or you know go through reruns of friends
and
i noticed that on social media all these
people were saying they were doing that
with one tree
hill i'm starting it over it's it's my
it's comforting me right now
and i was like wait a minute i'm
watching
some of our other friends you know the
gals from office ladies and and
zach and donald do fake doctors real
friends and i was like
is this our moment when we're all
actually at home
should we do this now yeah so i called
hillary and i said
you know you tell me if this is crazy
but
you left first and so i'm asking you
first what do you think and she was like
yeah i'm
in call joy and i was like all right i'm
handing her in and i called joy and we
were just like
yeah let's do this so it's gosh it was a
it was also a byproduct i think of
us slowing down and realizing that even
if we couldn't physically be together
we could do something like this and then
because everyone had work and projects
and pilots and movies and things that
you know we were having to navigate in a
coveted world
um it took us a while to get started
from that first call but
here we are and it's not on monday by
the way
you mentioned hillary clinton what was
it like to interview
hillary clinton she is
such an icon she was right about
everything
and i just am so inspired by her
gumption and her
her medal i mean she just never gives up
and really lives a life of service and
is so wise and so funny
most people don't know she has the
driest
most whip-smart sense of humor she's a
legend
so yeah that that episode of work in
progress is one that i'm particularly
uh proud of as people listen to drama
queens it premieres on the 21st
what will we learn that you guys haven't
i guess shared or talked about before
oh man i mean there are so many things
that
we're even learning you know fans have
asked us so many times
when we get together we'll do you know
conventions or reunions
and people say what was your favorite
episode what was it like to do this
scene
and this and we kind of look at each
other and we always feel so bad we're
like guys we don't remember
because there you know there's 187
episodes of the show which is
crazy but for us i did the math actually
i broke it down on an average of you
know
we used to film between 12 and 18 hours
a day and so i did the averages in time
and then looked at how many days we shot
the episodes and at
the most conservative estimates we spent
35
000 hours filming nine seasons of our
show
and so there's just stuff we don't
remember
and we filmed we didn't like you don't
film in a perfect edit with a soundtrack
and the music and the moment where they
do the close-up
you know you're actually doing it right
and so for us
not having seen we're starting at the
beginning not having seen the pilot
since it aired in 2003
why are you a cheerleader i mean no
offense or anything but you're about the
least cherry person i know
pilate is worth
we just watched the second episode and
all of us were crying at the end and we
were like wait it's
really it really holds up it really
works but we just haven't experienced it
like that so this is actually
our first time to experience the show
the way the fans have
and it feels really cool yeah oh that's
awesome
you guys have all though on the flip
side been very vocal
about some of the trauma on set that you
guys have experienced and i think it's
amazing that you have been able
to to talk about those experiences and
hopefully other
casts are learning from your guys's
experience
what will be the most i guess difficult
part about
talking about that and reliving those
moments you know what's really
interesting i think we're lucky
in that we're all years out from this
we've had a lot of the conversations
that are really hard really emotional
really required the support of our whole
ecosystem of women who are on that show
we've done that yeah we're not like
we're not here to put our trauma on
display
um and we're certainly not here to put
people on the spot we're not
hiding anything like we're pretty no
holds barred we're bold women
um who are very blunt and frank
but we're all
i think so fortunate to be in these
positions where we've had each other
you know we've we've been able to do our
processing and at this point
like i'm sure there are some men we
worked for who are very scared
and they probably should be but you know
you didn't want to get called out for it
you probably shouldn't have paid that
way
um but i'm i'm really happy to say that
this feels joyful
it doesn't feel like picking at a scab
it feels like a reclamation we're taking
back what was ours we're taking back the
thing we made
we're taking back our 35 000 hours no
boss who came to town from time to time
or a person who was a creep
um you know on a specific day or during
a specific incident they don't own that
we own it
yeah and it it feels really really fun
to be creating something out of our work
sure will you invite other cast members
oh yeah there's so many of us i know i
can't
wait i just like it's gonna be a parade
of all our favorite humans it's going to
be okay
do you guys have you put those invites
out yet can you tease oh we have a we
have a group text that literally
everyone who's ever been on the show is
on
um and so oh yeah everyone
every single person from our show um
yeah and so when we decided that we were
gonna do this
long before we announced it we we told
everybody what was up
what our plans were and just said look
we obviously want to have each and every
one of you on
if you don't want to come on that's
totally okay um
no hard feelings but if you do we can't
wait to you know
audibly hug you and and everyone has
just been
so excited everybody's pumped i love
that
i know you mentioned you guys have been
approached for reboots and reunions but
seeing the success i mean the friends
reunion
gossip girl is getting rebooted now that
this is really becoming such a positive
thing
would you ever consider a reunion
a reboot what would it look like
if you if you could fish your wish i
mean
i can't spell all of our secrets but i'd
say never say never is it something
that's being talked about
okay but you can't
[Laughter]
you're playing brook again i mean
she's the coolest she is the coolest i
will say that
no let's also talk about good sam really
fast it's a cbs
medical drama what sets it apart from
other medical dramas honestly
the writing i mean katie wesh is just
such a phenomenal writer
and you know the films i've been making
over the last couple years and the
streaming shows i've been doing
with the podcast i was like i think
that's my wheelhouse i don't know that i
want to go back to the grind of network
tv
and we have a friend in common um
an agent who i do a lot of development
work with and he said you've got to read
this script i was like i'm not reading
it
he said you've got to read it and i was
like okay if i'll read it
and i got to the end of it and i just
went well looks like i'm going back to
network tv this is
so good it is it's one of the best
scripts i've read in
years and it's charming and it's witty
and it's smart and it's unapologetic
and it's emotional and it it gives
people permission to really think about
things and feel things and be on a ride
i
i think it has some of the same kind of
secret sauce
that probably has made one tree he'll
last for so long when characters are
just
really good and there and the writing is
sharp
it feels like catching lightning in a
bottle how are you
a little crazy i'm seeing things honey
me too this movie false positive was
i feel like wild is a good way to
describe it
i initially thought it was going to be a
rom-com and then i watched it
and it was definitely not a rom-com
how would you describe it oh my gosh
i i think what i responded to
and and the thing that feels really true
for me now is that this is a
true psychological horror it puts you in
the position where you really don't know
uh if the characters are seeing things
or if they're really experiencing things
and it creates just a general feeling of
of disney's and
oh i remember when alana sent me the
script reading through it i just got
like
more and more uncomfortable uh and by
the end my mind was blown
so yeah wild feels right
you